ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre
delvoye le président de la république
l'a toujours dit pour qu'il ait une
réforme des retraites en 2025 faut que
le système soit équilibré et d'ailleurs
monsieur le premier ministre la viande
confirmé devant le conseil économique et
social puisqu'il a bien dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas laisser filer un déficit que
vivre en déficit n'était pas forcément
le signe d'une bonne santé ou d'une
bonne gestion que le rapport cotisants
pensionnés n'étant pas favorable le
système allait se dégrader et il a même
été précisée à rodez que si le déficit
est entre vite eddie milliard et ben il
faudra dire qu'il faut travailler
davantage
le rapport du cor a révélé ce qui avait
déjà été dit en juin à savoir un déficit
autour de 10 ans de 8 à 17 milliard
d'euros donc je voulais savoir
maintenant que nous sommes au pied du
mur et c'est au pied du mur qu'on voit
le maçon donc quelles sont les réformes
que vous allez proposer en tout cas les
mesures que vous allez proposer pour
équilibrer le système de santé
[Applaudissements]